an investigation by dw's investigative
team has found
that the myanmar army is brainwashing
its soldiers
and controlling every aspect of their
life even down to their finances
my colleagues spoke to three defectors
two of whom are high-ranking officers
the conversations were mainly over
messaging apps and through some
audio and video calls i'll be speaking
to one of my colleagues who conducted
the investigation in a minute
but here is a bit of what two of the
defect tests said
everything is monitored they want to
turn people into robots
who don't think for themselves
and another defector said if people post
political things
they can be arrested and put in jail for
three or four weeks
and joining me on the line is my
colleague naomi conrad who was part of
the team that conducted this
investigation
naomi where are these defectors you
spoke to and why did they defect
right so i'm afraid i can't tell you
very much about where they are exactly
um because obviously they're not safe
and the army is hunting down as far as
we know defectors
all i can tell you is that two iron high
i'm hiding in myanmar
moving from one safe house to the next
every day another one is across the
board in india but again i can't tell
you where exactly
um all three men decided to defect
following the army takeover earlier this
year
uh under what is basically a brutal
crackdown on civilians protesting this
takeover
one man said i can't be part of an
institution that took part in an illegal
coup
so uh very much because of the coup um
they all defected
did they provide any explanation as to
why the army decided to take power in
this manner
in myanmar so none of these men
are actually part of the highest
echelons of the army but they're all
very clear that they think the coup took
place because the army was afraid that
it was losing power
so the elections last late last year saw
a landslide for the governing national
league for democracy
uh which basically meant that you know
the army was afraid it might lose its
grip on power um and one man was pretty
clear he said you know the
the army wants to turn the entire
country into a military base
meaning that you know the army wants to
take control of the whole country
and not cede any power to to elected
civilians or elected politicians
naomi how is the army able to wield so
much influence in myanmar
so the army myanmar is basically a very
powerful state within the myanmar state
if we look very briefly at the history
of myanmar basically myanmar has been
governed
governed by the military for most of its
recent
history since it gained independence
from the uk made it from britain
basically and in that time the army
managed to amass great wealth so
land economic and financial power
for a long time it was basically
impossible to do business in myanmar
without
going through the army or affiliated
businesses of the army
and what they've also done is you know
established their own court system
they're not
accountable to the civilian courts they
run their own universities
so a very powerful yet very opaque
state within the estate that's basically
accountable to no one
what did these defectors tell you did
they provide a glimpse into the life
of an average soldier in myanmar
they did they did and it's a very
cloistered a very strictly monitored
life i mean they were very clear that
the army has a facebook monitoring team
that you know
looks at all their social media activity
and also hauls people in that you know
maybe
voice their support for the national
league for democracy or criticize
uh the government there's also a lot of
propaganda um
officers have to take part in a
three-month training course which you
know
uh paints the army is the savior's the
defender of myanmar against the muslims
there's a lot of anti-muslim rhetoric
that
soldiers are fed the three men that we
talked to they didn't necessarily
believe all this propaganda
um but they knew well enough that they
couldn't voice any criticism because
that would have been dangerous
and also uh right now um they're
basically
soldiers are basically living this this
life on the base that they're not
allowed to leave they need to ask their
superiors if they want to leave
they have to do all their shopping on
their bases their schools on the bases
so i think an average soldier you could
say has
very little to no contact with civilians
you did mention earlier that these three
defectors are in a dangerous
situation but for the moment being are
they safe
i wouldn't say they're safe so it seems
pretty clear that the army has drawn
up a list of wanted activists
and journalists and also of defectors
and uh they haven't published this
because
it's obviously embarrassing for them to
to publish how many people have have
left the army despite the the great
danger
but they're hunting down these people
those are putting a lot of pressure on
the defectors families i mean
one man told us that his parents
received threatening phone calls
basically telling them you know where's
your son if you don't tell us where your
son is then
we'll come and get you um at which point
he's severed all communication with his
family so they're in a very dangerous
situation they're
trying to leave the country um but they
know that even if they make it to
thailand or to india they're not
necessarily safe there i mean they could
also get
deported back it's a very complex
situation at the moment they don't
really know
how to stay safe other than you know
move from one safe house to the next
they've obviously thrown away the phones
they had when they were still on the
military base but
it's dangerous and they're trying to
remain safe naomi conrad thank you very
much
for your reporting